[Music]
foreign
yeah we got a great show for you guys uh
this is just a reminder please keep
table talk to them when I'm a voice of
looking at your cell phones uh and
please do not Heckle uh the performers I
also just another note um if you get
called on stage there's a little switch
on the microphone so just turn that
switch on uh and you should be good to
go without further Ado please give it up
you're also the evening Hans Kim
everybody
hello guys my name is Hans Kim and
welcome to the Daily Show
hello guys
okay we're gonna really use the buckets
right now I don't know where the buckets
went uh the buckets is where your names
go and then we pick out a name and then
we want you guys try to [__] each other
um we usually get straight people we are
very lgbtqia plus friendly uh so if
you're that that's cool too uh we won't
tell Governor Abbott that we're here uh
there we go
the buckets are dusting oh wow pockets
are looking a little poetry tonight we
got slips of paper guys we need you to
sign up or else we don't have a show
we're gonna have
one 90 minute day so far
right not much a couple really struggle
up here if no one else signs up it's
it's gonna turn ugly
they're gonna start
dating and it's gonna watch a full
relationship form and break up tonight
that's that's what you signed up for
uh we have a lovely guest tonight this
guy is a very funny comedian he was
recently on the kill Tony podcast where
he says I'm very very offensive jokes
um
mostly about
the Guatemalans who he hates
uh give it up for one of the chief
Venezuelan comedians a guy who hates
Guatemalans but it's okay because he's
like Venezuelan which is the same thing
um
give it up for Francisco Rincon
Francisco
a Mexican can fix anything
thank you guys uh I thought you were a
watermelon I was watermelon not a albino
Guatemalan okay
I'm very happy to be here um the winner
gets to do a threesome right with us
yeah you guys have to pour some we got
to have sex with the contestants just
kidding please sign up let's not try to
scare them off we only got two so far
all right you do not have to do anything
with anyone except go on a date which
might not be safe for women half out
here for women
what's your uh dating situation like
um I have a girlfriend and she's color
white uh we met on Craigslist
if you didn't hear that she has a color
white
yeah she's a rescue
and uh she's white trash
We're not gonna have any kids I don't
think everybody should be having kids we
need to be more responsible only
responsible Mexican in the world right
no a lot of people think I'm Mexican I'm
not that's gross I am I am Venezuelan
way better and uh yeah she's white trash
in my wet back we're not gonna bring wet
trash into the world it's not gonna
happen that trash not gonna need any
value it's okay he's
he's a Mexican
yeah I'm Mexican he's allowed to say
this
um so well if you signed up you're going
up now
we're gonna go to the charade before
this guy signs up
we need a woman
this guy needs a woman he's out here
alone unless he's gay which is combined
Dahlia Joe is a woman she signed up and
here she comes right up on stage please
take the stairs stage right
you're a woman or man
I thought I think he's a man I think so
Dahlia Joe coming up right over here to
those doors yes through that door I
should say Dahlia Joe thank you so much
for signing up
she found the stairs any moment now
she's really milking this entry Dalia
she's got a flare for the dramatic diet
looks like one of my sexy aunts oh hello
Daria
I've seen this in a telenovela before
media
hello Dahlia Joe how are you today
hello I am Dandy
that's new today it's a really fancy
word that's a big word I didn't take the
SAT you know yeah but we have your wife
Guatemalan I mean Venezuelan wife so we
can't go on a date
oh she knows that we're all taken
we can't play our dirty games with her
well wait no hold on a second now
I'm still good to go I'm playing dirty
games oh hell yeah she's the only just
kidding women that signed up and you can
tell are you dirty daddy in bed yeah oh
no I don't know what you're talking
about I don't do that my mom's out here
oh okay the whole family's here I'm
sorry
we got two generations of perverts in
the building no I will play this
inherited sexiness
so what's like uh your favorite thing to
do in the bedroom
clean it clean it oh you are a Mexican
yes ah absolutely
that's how you make so many babies in
clean bedrooms she's so Mexican when she
comes fabuloso come out of her [__]
butterflies
smells like lavender
hire her for your next cleaning project
she's got fabuloso in her [__]
he said it not me
a Mexican mom
she's milking some of that Mexican
privilege
so that sweet sweet
gravy train that those Mexicans are on
what is uh your favorite word in Spanish
she's a Mexican how can you tell because
you you hear her mom
where where don't where are you from
oh Indiana
the classic Indiana tan no
my mom says we're confused okay sexually
or racially both
you are in the South sport Brooklyn
raised in Texas went to high school on
the border of Mexico but were full
Egyptian oh no oh wow that's about some
racist pedigree I've ever heard Brooklyn
racism Texas racism Egyptian racism yes
which group do you hate the most all of
them
whoa she's got Egyptian Pride we've got
an Egyptian supremacist in the crowd
Cleopatra running the roost here
she does have the attitude of a Mexican
grandma
behave are you gonna
Mexican from Egypt that's right yeah
we're all Mexican yeah yeah deep down
inside Mexicans Mexican not Mexican not
Mexicans well let's hope that this next
contestant is a Mexican also
it's Mike the only other guy that signed
up on time Mike here he comes oh that's
awesome oh my God saw me and he was like
I'm out
Mike is in he's ditched his date and
he's coming around to date you Dahlia
are you single Dalia yes nice yeah yeah
are you a virgin yes me too yeah me too
a version of what
a Mexican yes he actually is Mike
Mike is not Mexican
so we're gonna do one minute of you guys
dating so actually it's 90 seconds 90
seconds of you guys dating each other so
go ahead and date each other starting
now how are you Mike I am doing also
fantastic nice where are you from Mike
uh originally
uh Toronto nice what made you come here
uh work nice why else does anyone else
come to Texas because they love it
that's a red flag
they love it in Texas Texas is great
and so what do you do for work I'm an
engineer what kind uh I guess chemical
but now I do more Hardware nice you have
a 401k I do I do have a 401k do you have
a Roth IRA I do as well oh my God that
sucks you should have an IRA because
then I know that you make more money
that's why I don't like people that have
Roth IRAs
so that's a flag for you big flag that's
okay well good we'll work on it yeah are
you an accountant no I used to be though
but I'm not anymore well that explains
everything yeah yeah so what do you do
now
oh I am
um I I'm a business analyst I work with
developers but I used to be in finance
okay and just pivoted my career recently
to to being more on the I.T side ah okay
product and Technology yeah what's your
take on Tech nowadays
well I think that Tech is everywhere so
I think it's a good thing to know it
any kids not yet never never
they're too expensive and they're too
dirty and time
give it up for Dahlia Joe
he's definitely not Mexican
she hates kids
dirty and what did you call them
smelly expensive oh sounds like
okay
good to know Mike are you single or are
you here dating for real
here for real oh let that mic right by
your chin yeah so I think that is what I
got no go do it you know this mic no
yeah right by your mic closer to your
mouth oh there we go he thinks
everything's a joke so we can hear you
but uh yeah so uh since the beginning of
the day clearly Dahlia was the man in
the relationship she was asking the
question so if you guys went home she's
gonna put a strap on a [__] the
[__] but um you say that like it's a
bad thing no it's a good thing it's a
really good thing because 2023 and you
know you need to let women do it
open-minded open [__]
um
but uh yeah that this in this was uh
it's my first time doing the show thank
you for having me okay that was a tough
uh date yeah I gave it a 7.5 out of 20.
oh
I've been on worse oh Mike what is the
worst date you've been on
um but that Mike right by your mouth so
we can hear you deliberating
it seemed with every sequential date she
had one more kid
ah surprise children
and you're not ready for that
responsibility you can barely manage a
microphone
but whose fault was that
not mine they're not my kid
is this a day or is this a appearance in
court for your child
payments I don't know what those are
called
so I don't know what's correct to do
nowadays in this country in this culture
but like there if I could be like hitch
for one second what has worked for me in
previous date is you have to compliment
her and tell her you know you have very
beautiful eyes and say things that come
naturally to youth to your heart and you
seem like a robot so I'm getting like
major like in Intel vibes from you and
that's fine because she seems like a
type of lady that can break you and take
you and make you her little little boy
that she's gonna [__] with a strap on
so
how do you know I'm not a robot
I don't know but you do look like a
robot also she's from Egypt you look
like a mummy so
you have kind eyes
like hopefully you're better with the
strap-on than a microphone
what's your favorite uh sex position
I don't think your mic is on
there how is it on yes
so I have to get my mom's strap on if I
hope you're better with a strap on than
a microphone I told you it goes down in
history our family
nice
yes
we got an angry Egyptian grandma in the
audience I am
oh
maybe you'll maybe you'll be a
grandmother in nine months
oh okay
I'm afraid
please don't do anything to me does
anyone want to date Dahlia's grand
mother oh yeah she's nice she's on the
market she's sexy he's putting herself
out there this guy wants to oh he's a
guy this guy looks like their family
you look Greek what are you I don't know
how is your hair
show us your chest holy [__]
he looks like the head of my dick this
guy
now you do have a beautiful head this is
a very Egyptian heavy show yeah a lot of
Egyptians here Mike what is your racial
ethnicity
Middle Eastern well okay we got some oh
I like it people from the Levant
from uh Mina I'm impressed you know that
word
thank you
so where are you from specifically don't
say Israel Canada
like that's not in the Middle East Mike
that's where I'm from though well you
just said you're from the Middle East my
family lineages yeah yeah okay so where
what country in the Middle East or is
your family from Israel hell yeah
who would have known with the jewfro
going on
I don't hide it so anything you want to
say to uh Dahlia maybe you're welcome
for the pyramids or
thanks for the 40 years in the desert
or maybe what's your Instagram account
let's link later you know
I've been a virgin all this life I kind
of wrecked a pyramid of my pants
you want to be a good leader bully
I'm going to behave
um so you said you're an engineer
um and uh serious question I'm not
trying to
uh be a you know
have you have you had sex before
please enlighten me yeah so okay
um do you do you like Dahlia or no I
think she's a nice person
90 seconds that we've talked right it's
a good start what do you what do you
think about Mike Dahlia he's a nice
person yeah for 90 seconds that we've
talked Yeah Yeah from a very shallow
perspective both of you are beautiful
that's all I have to say thank you thank
you yeah
that's very kind words from Venezuelan
thank you
yeah most Venezuelans are dead they
don't have any food
anyways
Mike who are you here with tonight
Courtney in the back Courtney in the
back
do you allow her to come to the front or
is she
I don't think she will because it's a
Jewish thing
is the hole in the sheet is that is that
your guy you you people
okay
um that's cool how did you meet Courtney
online okay you are an engineer
what gave it away
so do you enjoy uh online dating
uh with her yes oh right there
so you you met her online but then you
kept meeting her online
how does that work that's not how it
works at all oh I know but maybe maybe
in Venice no because you said with her
yes so I'm just wondering how many
interactions you had online before you
met in person
I've been through a lot before I met her
so I can't count yes okay pyramids in
Egypt yes yes so uh yeah you've been
through a lot uh what what is it uh that
you've been through what is like some of
the craziest things you've been through
the one I mentioned about the kids the
child lady the child we have having kids
while you were dating her yeah that was
weird
um
just a lot of like I don't know
flakiness still a lot of angry people
a lot of I don't know I I can't really
explain it
but okay
well I'm sorry that uh you have to deal
with that a lot of flakiness you're in
America now not Canada yeah that place
is that so uh yeah what uh what are you
looking for in a date
uh just someone with a sense of humor
okay so are you trying to date me or
are you open to it
no are you
are you are you bisexual Mike no no
but are you serious
have you been bacon about it
anyways Dahlia
what are you looking for in a date
a normal man a normal man
can you describe what uh your ideal man
would be like yes okay
he has two eyes two he has a nose he has
a mouth with a pretty smile yeah he
brushes his teeth sounds like you're
describing a woman
there's no man that does all this
I know
preferably one that's not married
yeah
um one that has a 401k okay well that's
an IRA are you an American yeah I think
I can find you a man you think yeah that
you can give the papers to and then
like a 90 Day Fiance type thing
that probably won't work for me no no no
who depends he'll love you how much he
willing to pay me
no he loves you
we'll give you a Roth IRA no an IRA that
means you make more money I know yeah
so uh yeah you you seem like you're
pretty well versed in Tech you're like
all up in the finances like what's like
the richest guy you've ever dated
I haven't
you haven't dated any Richmond
who is the richest of all the who's like
the Starbucks barista
the Shawarma Barista my last 20-year
relationship was the richest man who was
not rich at all he was 20 you stayed
with him for 20 years and he didn't even
have a Roth IRA no
he did have a taxable brokerage account
though
okay does that make you wet or well I
had to tell him what to invest in oh so
you're like helping him with the stocks
trying to
you know what they say if you help a man
with the stocks you gotta suck his [__]
my mom is here
she was completely celibate for 20 years
she never
had any naughty thoughts
so uh any Venezuelan dating advice for
this lovely couple
I will say you know
um nowadays 2023 we we want to give a
woman too much power but I think women
like to be treated the way they were
treated back in the good old days
when you know you the man take care of
the house the man pay their bills and
then they just stay home and clean and
look over the kids I think that's the
way it should be that's the the only way
to a happy marriage and relationship you
take care of the house you pay the bills
you're the man of the house you don't
ask for questions you take care of
business
you take care of business and then she's
at home and she's living her best life
watching TV 90 Day Fiance you know doing
uh bath bubbles or whatever
and uh keeping the the house clean and
then when your man comes home from from
a long story day at work you get on your
knees and you suck that cook
suck that cook there's a cook involved
no I don't know Waylon yeah I don't know
I don't know anything about life well
Dalia be prepared to give up your
driver's license and sit in the back
because we're doing this old school
style Middle East Side no just kidding
well thank you so much for going on this
date you guys or did it and now we're
gonna watch from the back
um well you guys you were great
thank you so much Dahlia and Mike went
on a date
I hope both of you find low
is hard to find because he comes and
then you get all excited and then like
three weeks after you're like oh this
person is boring or whatever yeah I hate
it yeah you gotta have a good return
policy that's why I get my wife at
Amazon yeah you you know you know you
really like someone when for how long
after you come you're willing to call
the Uber
yeah if you call an Uber right away then
it's like poor Hansen says long as soon
as they walk in the apartment he's
calling the Uber
all right four minutes of hot passionate
sex and then
Uber is here touching my own time
that's that's my image of hand coming
tomorrow
I'm very mechanical all right I'm like a
sex robot
in an hour
we got a man straight man named Morgan
line wall oh wow the guy give it up for
Morgan guy has the name of a billionaire
so no women have signed up so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna get a woman to
be sexually attracted to Morgan through
a series of questions and then a woman
will naturally want to come up or or any
any man that are willing to nobody has
shown any interest yet turn the mic on
please
hey what's up Morgan how are you today
good man what's your dating situation
like
um very single uh I dated a girl we went
on a coffee date and I got a nine dollar
two nine dollar matcha latte so wow yeah
super expensive to date huh you know
about that wow you're counting every
penny yes I was yes I thought the last
guy was Jewish yeah no I'm I'm actually
Jewish I'm well you're Jewish too did
you not know that no I did I just did it
for German oh okay he is a very funny
comedian he is uh very accomplished he
has a mustache have you tried growing
hair maybe that might help I used to
have a Jew fro and it kind of started
thinning I'm not bald bald but it was
like thinning and I was like let me just
go full manly guy
yeah I do for always when you grow your
hair because you don't want to spend
money getting a haircut yeah regardless
of that's the my strategy all right Mike
look at Morgan this is future
he is your Alpha
all right anybody wanna Morgan what's
the most Alpha thing about you
the most Alpha thing about me is I'm
very open that I lived in New York City
trying to be on Broadway
I was a musical theater actor and right
into the closet no I'm straight I'm a
straight okay I'm very straight and like
anything else
right Broadway yeah like me admitting
like I lived in New York trying to be on
Broadway and failed is like pretty Alpha
right ladies wow who doesn't love that
yep
can you give us a little ditty a little
brick not on the first day dude okay I
mean I think that that might get a
couple of women interested what do you
want me to I'll say what do you want me
to sing can you sing uh what's like a
nice balance yeah I don't know her any
Harry Styles just what you think Harry
Styles what do I think Harry said I just
wanna love you in the in the back wow a
song about anal sex let's go to the back
and let me love you
Jewish Harry Styles yeah did I nail it
did I get does anybody know Harry Styles
did I get it close at all not a One
Direction fans yeah oh um I forgot he
was in they filmed that music video on
the log you know and they all sit on the
log on the beach the ladies know this
they filmed that like uh kind of near my
house so I know that log so that he is
close to fame yeah Broadway he was near
a log
I think that's the most uh style your
hair is ever gonna get wow okay well
that was yeah bombed huh how did that
feel huh I'm a bad person uh hey Morgan
do you have any like technique when you
go on a day like what are you asking
like or what has worked before any
advice for a young man out there trying
to make it in this tough world
of expensive ladies
you know I naturally talk a lot I'm a
bit of a talker and so I have to
actively work against that and just put
all my focus on them and pretend to be
very very interested in them yeah
pretend to care and that doesn't change
why and sometimes I am sometimes you
fake it till you make it you're like oh
wow this person is cool
you know right and sometimes for a
chance yeah but then I end up talking
and
we just kind of take over at some point
I don't mean to yeah he's a talker yeah
just a yappy Jew I said better a talker
than a stalker it's kind of whatever
yeah so
if you go on a date if if she's talking
you're winning let her talk as much as
possible ask questions pretend like
you're listening you gotta win the dates
hopefully listen but but then like fake
it till you make a thing it's true
because that happened to my girlfriend
and then she kept talking and then I had
to have been pretending like I'm
listening um yeah this whole time I mean
the whole point I think is like the
whole pretending thing is like you find
someone that you do want that's the
whole point he's like I do like talking
to someone that you want to be Pretender
or not that's nice like well I'm faking
who I am but it's like so easy yeah I'm
good at being fake me I'm a great fake
me okay anyone interested uh
they say to repeat the last three words
I'm a sweet I know I know all about like
the feminine side I know like oh you
you look beautiful do you know you know
what a wedge is uh like a shoe yes yeah
oh he knows what a wedge is I don't know
wedges and a sundress that looks great
so we all know sundresses you know like
Kendra Scottish you know what a Balayage
is
what say again Balayage no [__] I don't
he's a he's a man he doesn't care about
your stupid hair ladies what is a
Balayage it's like uh where you color
your hair
is this a woman holy [__] oh okay nice
why don't you just come on up here oh
[__] yeah make out make the woman what's
up straight lady we've done yoga
together
very cool Black Swan Yoga
on oh there I am oh my God yeah we've
done some yoga together he's got kind of
a flat ass but it's okay wait a minute
are you at wait are you actually being
serious are you trying to be funny
because I have the I have the best ass
in Austin can you show everybody yeah
hold on
no don't don't put your ass out
yeah ladies give me a thumbs up if you
think you think's good ladies what do
you think what's up I just need okay we
got no thumbs up buddy okay I'm sorry
I'm sorry okay big and good two
different things but flat ass I don't
have a flat ass there was just a way for
me to get you to show something I don't
know I'm gonna start pretending to be
interested
to ask me questions about my okay one
thing I want to know
you've been tested for STDs
uh
well should I really give the real
answer I have never been tested for an
STD how many times have you slept with
women without a condom uh like not a
girlfriend like a relationship yeah not
a relationship ah I don't know five to
ten somewhere okay somewhere okay so you
just expect your girlfriends to get
tested for you
no I never asked them to get tested so
you just don't care
yeah yeah
most guys I don't have a better answer
than that I don't I yeah I don't know
okay that's cool okay that's cool I
should I'm an [__] yeah I mean it's
laziness uh in England once I thought I
had something and I went to a like a
doctor thing in England in London
somewhere and uh I'm cultured by the way
very cool uh and then uh yeah I just
ended up not staying I got a little you
know bored he just got bored at the the
office lady wow this chick knows how to
woo the guys huh time
give it up for the spiciest date I've
ever seen yeah I see these on their
first date but yeah that's cool
about himself he just you know he talks
a lot he pretends to care I just need to
know the basics can't cross a little bad
in this first party interview didn't I
well he is he's trying to be like
stupidly honest you know I was just
trying to really get to the core that's
the best way to do yeah I think if a
girl asked me on the first day do you
have STDs I'm gonna think she has STD
that's a good point
got tested this [__] is filthy
after every new partner so it was
probably a week ago gotcha
hey dude sick she's responsible and
she's also out there lots of people
haven't had sex in months that's right
I'm on a date with like uh do you have
okay thank you this is the thing about
women talking too much yeah this is do
you want me to start talking too much I
don't know I can you're like do you have
any STDs do you want anything
I've never had one I just need to make
sure
what's your favorite STD
oh I wouldn't have a favorite
well it's like your least nobody hated
none of them you don't want any of them
how long ago was the last STD I've never
had an STD ever well I had a I had
prostatitis but it's probably because a
lot of questions too much no it's no I
didn't [__] any prostitute songs I uh
inflammation of the prostate so my Pro
my gooch was
in pain okay
not enough anymore about yourself huh
actually I am pretty single okay okay
yeah I moved here with a girl and then
we broke up I'm not sad whatever
okay he's definitely not still hung up
about that really oh for sure yeah how
was that I'm seeing a girl we've only
hung out a few times but her full name
is uh uh Shanley magana oh oh next it's
going out live oh it is yeah so I just
okay well her name is really Irish it
was very Irish was the most Irish thing
about her
I've we only hung out once she was the
one that got did she do it on Irish
goodbye
not not yours well you should have to
text me back so I know she flat ass okay
don't bring up the flat ass okay
nice round ass right everyone STDs
oh damn dude it's a Mexican he can do it
yeah you're the most Irish thing about
his girls uh it's uh her vagina produces
a lot of G's
any beer drinkers in the house wait what
word
you've got a good black guy boys
gist gist do you cook Morgan I do okay
cool what's your favorite thing to make
I make a nice little skirt steak with uh
those purple sweet potatoes yes and like
avocado I try to stay healthy okay how
do you season the steak like what do you
do salt and pepper salt olive oil okay
simple okay so I would make some herb
butter super easy and then you just
throw that on top right or chimichurri
chimichurri sauce right oh so all the
way thank you guys mean you guys met at
a yoga place
no we've just seen each other around and
then probably met he was from singing at
latchkey or something he's actually very
good he's a very talented singer don't
let that Harry Styles oppression fool
you yeah I know all right come on come
on yeah I was killing it at karaoke yeah
we have similar interests already this
is a good place uh latchkey karaoke is
our Broadway in Austin yeah he made it I
made it to Broadway definitely do you
like your mom
we have a tough relationship but yeah
okay she's like a very she's a Jewish
mom like a very scary her name's Linda
Fishman okay uh and she uh she this is
this is not a [__] she sees dead people
she like she's like a medium you know
the Long Island Medium she's not the
Long Island Medium but she like really
wants to be the Long Island Medium like
she she legitimately she has asked me
like Morgan do you see
people and I'm like what are you talking
about she's like she was at a funeral
and a little bunny came by I was like a
funeral of somebody she didn't know and
she went up to the father of the
deceased person and said your son just
spoke to me and he told me that he loves
you and it's going to be okay I bet she
gets invited to a lot of Futures yeah
it's a valuable commodity like I'd love
to talk to I'd love to talk to this
person this is only strange because my
mom's actually an astrologer wow
basically look at that it's like crazy
it's like I love my mother what guys
both have crazy mothers I would never
guess
your mom knows a lot of the medium and
you opened with I knew a log on a beach
once
yeah my mom's the the Suffolk County
medium dude oh my God my mom doesn't
reference formations more of a Norfolk
guy yeah yeah okay you'll be Nassau
County will you guys actually consider
uh like uh dating each other or is is it
absolutely out of you know your style or
whatever you're just looking at me well
I'm asking both but like you said like
oh no hero Morgan would we consider
dating it you know I think we we should
stay Yoga Yoga Pals I think so yoga Pals
I think though we have too much in
common you know it would just
be the loudest household ever well she
probably like it because I intentionally
try to find men who talk more than me
how did you notice his ass what happened
I don't even know why I said yeah
because you're a [__] liar because my
ass isn't great right I just wanted the
audience to get some play right like you
do have a very juicy ass it was pretty
juicy but I didn't get a single thumbs
up oh [__] that tiger
or they don't like asses that are big or
they're on a date with their man from
the Middle East wait man close your eyes
women give me a thumbs up if you like my
ass
there we [__] go dude got an Egyptian
are you [__] guys you [__] boys
try to keep me down the girls know
what's up he kills it in Egypt oh yeah
you have the ass of a camel thank you
yeah man I have a sexy camel curves yeah
man I'm a curvy [__] camel guy
uh why do you have that Camel what yoga
exercise would you recommend to someone
with a flat ass
I feel like I feel so alive when I go to
you I get to take my shirt off and
[__] intimidate everybody with my
women
what are women allowed to be topless in
Austin uh I didn't hear that but sure
but it's pretty cool private like so you
can be topless on the streets ladies uh
if you want but in a private
establishment like Creek in the cave if
somebody felt like kicking you out they
could so in yoga like you can wear a bra
in yoga definitely because all the girls
do that like I feel like yoga is just
like a weird meat market like I'm just
like okay this is but like everybody
farts it's like all so like for the yoga
predator
[__] babes and they're just like I I
don't know anyway they gotta like
crosses hanging between their two I have
arms I'm too busy focusing on the poses
yeah it's because you don't know them
like I mean I I anyway I can do the you
know anyway I just like it's like a wave
so are you bi I have had sex with more
women than you have uh-huh
I don't know it's a competition no you
haven't no not Han it's not Jason Morgan
but they didn't have dicks it was really
frustrating and like I don't like strap
ones I don't know well nowadays
hell like if I [__] I [__] this one girl
with a strap on and I didn't know where
the hell I was okay and identify as well
so we're in I'm pretending pretty hard
right now
what do you do that's different what do
you do eating [__] that men don't do
we do it like all the guys who do it
right do it I don't identify as a man
when you're going down on a girl no no I
would never well I identify as a man
just for fun but um it's probably
because I'm loud but no no the girl that
I dated said I was the gayest woman she
had ever been with
um but she couldn't make me come
so anyway and then I tried to [__] these
other girls thing to do I tried a lot
there was a ballerina that I [__] one
time and she was amazing but I made her
come she didn't make me come like guys
are annoying that's like a you problem
okay you're making everybody come but he
can't come
I mean guys can make I haven't had a
problem with you yeah it's tough for
girls to make me come too no they just
kind of hit me the right way I don't
know I haven't met anybody who can do it
yet yeah yeah Rubik's Cube crazy I think
I gave it a solid try like I just don't
think like I right like you gave it a
shot but you're not so you're straight I
would say yes because women are hard to
say no to could you imagine if I was
saying all this was like I try to [__]
all these guys and suck all their dicks
and it just wasn't big
girls could just try to be gay and have
like a year long you can't be like I
just had guys come in my mouth but I
never came in a dude's mouth honestly I
need I never could come in that guy's
mouth after my dick for an hour I don't
know what is the what is the how do you
usually what is the best way to make you
come what is like the highest percentage
success rate well if you go down on me
it takes about four minutes if you're
not an idiot and then you can [__] me
and I'll come again you gotta make it so
you're fake it pretend you care about
what her pussy's saying you just keep
making me I can just keep coming at that
point but I don't know it's not I know
it's not hard okay so do you have like
multiple orgasms you don't have orgasms
easily but when you do it comes in like
a lot oh if I yeah if I'm coming I just
keep coming you know wow sounds wow
sounds [__] really cool
ladies that get it they know what I'm
saying no they got that they got that
they got that uh they got that Nile
river flowing in their [__]
[Music]
keeps on giving me come I don't think
are you shaking and stuff or what I I
don't I'm not really you know it's like
kind of like Yo dude I date dude
this is my [__] date dude I guess
I'll ask the questions here I've never
made a woman come obviously but I don't
know so the reason I'm asking is because
I want to know what hints are out there
he starts shaking do I keep going
shaking if I tell you don't
[__] mover I'll kill you that means
if you use that voice I'm leaving oh no
nobody's left no oh you're making your
clothes so hard right now getting my
foreskin and getting the [__] out of the
[__]
so it's like like eighth time coming
right now dude ladies ladies all Shake
don't we when we're coming like don't we
all Shake a little bit right thumbs up
thumbs up if you think yeah wait man
close your eyes thumbs up yeah they've
been faking it this whole time okay um
do you guys make noise I don't know what
I do when I come I know that my
boyfriend's ex-boyfriends say that it
looks really good your boyfriend's
ex-boyfriend nice guy who you call them
I mean I don't dump guys I've been
[__] some of these people for 17
years like wait a minute
what you don't dump them not if
they're oh you'll just keep them as
options but they're forever yeah and
then yeah why not you've had a 17 year
long lover yeah yeah he's amazing yeah I
guess after 15 years you have to call
him a lover you can't just call them
it's life partner but uh you're breaking
his heart that's sad girlfriend and yeah
that's what I was gonna say when you
said lower it made it seem like he has
another person usually we have I mean
like I I'm not Paulie but like you keep
it open so yeah the person that man
cheat with no no he was the only one I
don't do that anymore yeah no it's fine
if you do I don't know this is a sick
person somebody has to do it right
expect women more I like because I was
running around being like I'm a feminist
I can't be a feminist and [__] a guy who
has a wife right yeah [__] not unless
you want to come
years ago and then I told my lover this
we're done no more and then he uh he
said okay cool and he goes I'm just
gonna tell the next girl the truth about
you because he had been telling them
that I was his sister uh
a real Texas relationship
or his business partner whichever worked
at the time because we did do business
together but
I'm in the whole business
oh business what a real entrepreneur
here
get out of the weed business well thank
you thank you thank you very good thank
you guys for
a long time ago so words per minute you
guys take the cake
the other comedian
Jessica
Jennifer Alyssa
the grandma from The Ring
that doesn't exist like time for another
man to see if he can attract a woman
from the stage so if this is how I see
if I have STDs or not I cheat on my wife
and then if he doesn't gets it I'm good
you know Venezuelan AIDS test
we got Kelly Shay Kelly Shea
they call him redheads this day back in
the good old days used to be a dirty
Ginger
he's just discovered wow that's the
offensive welcome Kelly Shea I can say
that because I'm Mexican dear Venezuelan
you're not even
he's the Mexican's Mexican
when I get in trouble I say I'm Mexican
all right let's get him in trouble real
quick
Kelly how are you pretty good everything
a lot quieter than the last guy oh
The Thinker he's strong and Silent
that's that's what I like to be I like
to be quiet and reserved until I spit
out my nonsense
nonsense what nonsense have you spit out
recently anything to do with women just
what is your overall thoughts and
feelings about women good I mean
I I got one I got I got a wife
thankfully that she's at home yeah she
has to stay at home and you're here
you're here cheating
dude I told her not to wait your wife is
uh color black right color black yes
okay
Francisco has recently started coloring
humans yes
we just have to color what color am I
Francisco yellow
I mean hello
what part of me is yellow
it's a stupid joke okay you're white
thank you you're thinking I always
wanted to hear someone say that I am
white so your eyes are yellow
[Laughter]
sounds like a disease they're black
they're just really small
Kelly what uh what is your racial uh
history have you ever been with an Asian
no I have not so I don't even know
Asians really existed since I've been
down where did you grow up New Orleans
and Dallas New Orleans yeah we don't
have a lot yeah
you just found out about Asians during
the pandemic yeah it just I was like
whoa [__] who what minorities you
wouldn't have to kill them
obviously around black people white
people that's that's how you get to
marry a black woman yep you're Southern
yeah I'm sorry you meet your your wife
blackpeoplemeet.com oh you did and they
they are like they allowed you in there
yeah I got she was a little nervous
whatever you have to be like at least
seven or 12 inches to ride or whatever
you got to be at least I'm talking about
the excise
talking about [__] size
a black person and a ginger you guys are
gonna have the most Venezuelan children
ever
our children will be starving at this
I don't I don't know I lost the
conversation I thought we were talking
about we were muttering racial slurs to
a specific audience member I was saying
that I thought to be able to go on
blackpeoplemeet.com you have to be black
and also have a black dick
I thought you just had to wanna meet
black people you can you can go live on
there and then they'll just be like all
right man they're being lying to me all
this time oh so accept you for who you
are
that is Francisco's impression of
African Americans that's not the
impression that's that's actually not a
term they use anymore they use highly
melanated
you guys you guys know that they don't
are you hoping you're not allowed to use
black you have to are you hoping that
some of the melanin rubs off on you yes
yes how much sunblocks you put on your
body how much what sunblock sunblock is
that a thing every morning you guys wake
up and just yeah every morning she's
like all right you can't have skin
cancer and neither can I so let's I'll
give you a [__] with some sunblock
you don't use the lube you use sunblock
yeah that's that's how we have sex every
morning is
protect ourselves from all the x-rays
the light dog too bright I'm getting
burned that's why you're in the shade
right now the shadow how is it with your
families dating interracially or your
family's cool yeah I mean they get along
everything yeah fine I mean I've I've
been around enough black people know not
to
wow what a racial scientist
sounds more races when he says things
but uh so yeah okay now I've always
wondered because my girlfriend she's
white like American white but uh our
families don't get along very well
because they don't
they don't understand each other the
best way to actually have families get
along really well is just for them to be
in different states and not talk to each
other that works too that's that's the
best part about living now for
Thanksgiving who has the best
Thanksgiving
on how long you're there for like if
you're there for like more than an hour
things start to get really heated but
after before that it's kind of like yeah
our side went my side wins swipe white
power yeah
because we get to see all those because
you guys think you guys don't run out of
food no at all
I don't know like he's from New Orleans
he's not one of the rich whites he's a
New Orleans white yeah once you guys
meet in New Orleans no we met again
online yeah wow you really did mean a
black people meet from Houston that's
we've met how we met online online in
Houston yeah I know they have the
internet
where was the first date what do you
guys do how do you guys uh Bond a little
we went to the Magic Time Machine it was
a incentive
it was like a knockoff Peter Pan at a
pizza place
hey just imagine Peter Pan but everybody
looks like they're working your second
shift as Peter Pan so we're really
trying to impress her with your
personality
personality it's my dry doll
non-confronting Personality yeah well
here he is ladies Kelly Shea he has a
wife he uh likes black people any takers
good I'm glad nobody likes me that's my
favorite part
this is kind of dumb to ask but does she
have a a big ass
no regularly is it bigger than Morgan
linewall's ass yeah it's about the same
size I look at I look at his ass and I'm
like oh pretty big now I can get turned
on by my wife that is pretty vain
so what is your favorite part of Morgan
leinwall's Body
where'd he go I have to look at him
again he's over at the mothership
bombing
aren't you supposed to be there yeah
oh well eventually
so anyway
50 minutes to go possibly not get on
me
on the next round can we get like single
people to see if yeah can we get someone
that's actually trying to do you can
just bring up Alyssa again and then she
could just have um live and we [__]
every day and she can hang out together
because you're both redheaded yeah
that's actually how we met we were like
hey there are no gingers let's [__]
kick it get under my umbrella I got
sunblock
yeah what is your favorite thing about
redheads
I don't know I've met very many of them
so
uh let's send this guy back back not
like that that was like that was my
introduction to redheads as well there's
my introduction to Asians and she was my
introduction to redheads there's no
Ginger Meetup there's only black people
I wish there was like in college there
actually was that like it was kind of
like a thing but after a while you're
like this might be like a white power
meeting so we decided that we had to
call it
the most gingery of the gingers yeah
that's cool man you got you're you know
you are white yes that's great
representation I hope so the whites
what's your uh what's the thing that
your black wife was shocked by like
white your something that you do that's
white
uh
mayonnaise or pay your taxes
thing that she was shocked by that I
knew
maybe your penis size like you have a
big dick yeah she was like wow that
looks exactly like abortions yeah
they're big almost black man
they don't have a lot of black people in
Venezuela they're like albino anaconda
in this [__] all right
then where you get all your TV
references from yeah some guy being like
Oh you doing [__] yeah do you
eat crocodile crocodile in Louisiana you
eat alligator out there it's pretty good
I'm Montana people
did you just say New Zealand
I don't even think it's a threat in the
audience it's all the same all those
ones I have I have gone to Australian
eating crocodile so that was nice to try
nice good for you we don't care
all right we care about New Orleans and
Louisiana well I'm sorry the difference
of crocodile and alligator the
difference is it's just one's meteor
okay hopefully your girlfriend tries the
meteor version
um well thank you Kelly you're married
you don't need this I know how many
years have you been married
uh one year oh only one year but I've
been together with her for eight or nine
I don't know oh okay so you have about
three more years to go yeah and then
three more years until we're like all
right let's get on stage together and
who can be with Francisco's life who
gave who covet first uh I gave her covet
hell yeah white power oh yeah
that is you know was it in a blanket
like a coveted blanket I guess that's
more Native American thing thanks all
right well I ran to rub my face on her I
ran out of racist jokes to dude
thank you Kelly for being white thank
you
wish you the best in your marriage she's
married this is the success story this
is you guys be married for 12 months
Abraham
feeling wrong you know these guys
beautiful yeah hey maybe maybe uh your
mom wants to come meet him
he's very handsome look at him he looks
like a a tight like a elephant from
Thailand
no his face like he looks can you remove
your hand don't make fun of his face no
but he looks like a like a sweet little
elephant from Thailand nobody knows what
you're talking about like if you look at
Thailand like the elephants that they
have his face that is villains are weird
dude anyways thank you for coming
um you have a very human face thank you
uh what is the most human thing about
you
warmth of empathy he likes to eat
peanuts
oh yeah pick things up with your nose I
like a good big dick
I'm sorry has anyone ever told you that
your face looks like an elephant from
Thailand before yes they've said that
this guy every time I see this [__]
guy oh you know him can you remove your
hat or no
you're just gonna do the same joke about
my head looking like your dick
that's not what I was gonna say I was
gonna say that his head looks like my
dick
Alyssa's already giving you an STD test
from the back right now
so you've never seen a head so big are
there any women on this show right no
this is a sausage face
Dudes Only no women maybe we bring Dalia
back because she they seem like the guy
they could be a good match no Delia
the first lady the first lady of the
show
her mother is [__] scary you should
be yelling like that about my girlfriend
like that about my girlfriend what do
you call it a boiler mommy's my
girlfriend in Arabic
Tata
Dahlia you want to come here and date
this guy
no he'll go he's not afraid he's just a
girl man he has money look he's wearing
a La Crosse that's the IRA
he has a hat that he kept the receipt if
you don't pay attention to him he's
gonna return it tomorrow
at the Marshalls he wants to tap the
options he wants to tap that Tata oh
yeah nice
oh Dahlia is coming up also he uh he's
he's not Hamas homosexual
yeah he's from Egypt he's a hummus
sexual
that's what I try to say but my English
is not oh really yeah
uh well Dalia though give it up for
Dahlia she's up here again second woman
only two women she's 50 of the women
give it up for Dahlia
she's a woman
Dahlia what made you come up for a
second time tonight
some he is yeah Dalia from from one to
ten how big will you rate him
how big do you think his [__] is yeah I
don't know from
um from Venezuelan to Black
to
North Carolina's girlfriend
wow dildo
what she gonna treat your hair like a
dildo
like a dildo
that's Francisco
with the Venezuelan accent man is that a
mess let's go with the Venezuelan
validated voice no she she wants to put
your head
doing a Southern accent
turducking of accidents
and she wants to put it in her vagina
how many different cultures are up here
I would say so yeah are you disappointed
that uh uh Philip
Philip Abraham is not wearing a fez no
I'm not disappointed at all I say to
each his own be what you are do what you
want to do you like uh baseball cap
what what uh sport do you guys play in
Egypt cricket
you guys have a cricket team yeah we
play cricket in Egypt hence I think I
interrupted is that the uh yeah is that
what you guys experiments we build a lot
of pyramids instead of baseball hats you
guys wear Cricket hats yeah and enslaved
Jews yeah
do you think that they'll say it like
that this guy is dark no he didn't you
skin and his jokes are you ever uh have
you ever been uh wondering about this
guy's cricket bat no his pants no no
okay
um 401k and an IRA will you suck his
cricket full brokerage account yes I see
I like the stock options as well what
what's that stock options oh yeah see
he's got some stockers and he's he's
he's he's his phone company is also
Cricket Mobile yeah and he sells a
Cricket phone
hello how many phone do you do you want
three for that was I'm sorry
you eat crickets over there
uh you guys want to go on a date
90 seconds we are on a date right a day
right yeah go ahead and go do more of it
starting now okay don't [__] start
interviewing me like you did the other
guy like I interviewed Mike rapid
questions and [__] okay then you
interview me yeah I like your boots you
like my boobs yeah what
you might steep come on guys
boots oh my boots yeah okay you got a
one-track mind no you're a dirty girl
the track's up there are you a dirty
girl no
uh I cleaned all right all right what do
you what do you do for hobbies
uh we're not pegging guys what do you do
I go hiking
I go running I go swimming go canoeing
you sound very active but you don't have
the body of an active woman
that's because you ain't see me naked
baby
okay
sad thing you never will you just named
the most active thing I'm a rock climber
I [__] it no I don't climb rocks I'm
terrible asking my sister I can't do
that okay do you tried it here can't do
it all right just fall okay so you go
you do a lot of back outdoor activities
yeah I like outdoor activities okay and
you ask me a question yeah so what do
you like to do for fun what's your hobby
what do I do yeah what do you do
um
I like to [__]
and time no as a dating coach you did
everything wrong
yes what did I do why yeah you cannot
say I Wanna [__] in the first date you
have to you have to first compliment her
make her feel like she's in a
comfortable place make her feel like the
center of attention you told her the
boot no no no because when you asked
about the activities you said something
stupid came out of your mouth
[__] [__] and uh and then at the
end and she's like what do you like to
do and you're like I like to [__]
I thought that she had a camel toe and
you removed that from her
all right this is why there's so many
Mexicans and not that many Egyptians
that's right
you gotta get some of that nut and that
and seduction in your game what do you
usually say to women what's your pickup
line
uh hello hello he's like getting my Uber
quick
they're like have you uh
do you want to renew your car's warranty
because he said hello hello
um Philip what is your uh favorite way
to just talk to people do you like to
ask them about their job or what what do
you like to talk to people about
politics
uh just like maybe what they're
passionate about what are you passionate
about
[__]
and you bring that up in conversation no
really I'm not [__] but
um
honestly feel that you only get to
pursue your passion once a week you only
last three minutes
30 minutes of passion I wish I love
doing these early tuber now I gotta wait
seven days so that's pretty optimistic
because that's a compliment thank you
um yeah I'm passionate about people I
like people I like meeting people I like
talking to people you like [__]
people I like [__] [__] people
over yeah he's Egyptian
oh yeah good at three card money or
whatever you want to write my uh my
carpet or my camel
I don't know
I don't know anything it's a man who's
very hungry Phillips so what is uh what
is something that you're doing like uh
any any like projects that you're
working on are you building something
are you just looking at people and
appreciating them
projects that I'm doing
um I built a mannequin out of wood and
you [__] it
I mean that's the goal
it's not quite there you built a
mannequin out of wood that's hard to do
yeah I've got a lot of sanding to do at
this stage oh gosh you want it smooth
yeah because you want a real smooth move
it up
I think I should leave you probably
watching you know he probably watch
Pinocchio and he was like What if I
build my own little boy and he becomes
one and then [__] it yeah you can never
go soft on me then
Dahlia what do you think about this
strange man from Egypt
he was he was a good looking guy but
then he ruined himself but I think Dalia
this goes right I think that is going to
give him another chance uh but I don't
know I don't think he puts deodorant
under his armpits
yeah
deodorant are you into that yeah okay
let me see what I can do
does your mannequin need deodorant
no it smells pretty good it's made out
of Sandalwood so
yeah
um who will you choose between Mike
and this [__] head Mike
Mike's got a juicy ass I'll tell you
that
no that was Morgan with the juicy ass no
no the two guys that you dated tonight
the two guys that I dated are you single
I am single
no kid no kid
single mic is not saying
you win by default by default you would
no other options teach him a few things
what would you teach him be okay how to
be a good gentleman no but you say you
like to clean right so you can clean his
dirty mouth right filthy boy
[Laughter]
and he does not the market today at
Mueller
and pretty soap I can put in his mouth
oh yeah and you feel like lavender you
could put whatever you want to put soap
in his mouth and he'll put a cog in her
ass and you're good to go
he likes Sandalwood
vendor exactly make sure the dildo
Sandalwood yeah I like it all filled up
so I will say this I like how you went
for the boots complimenting the boots
and then she thought you were talking
about her boobs so that that that
exposed her and and you opened the door
the sexual door she did because you were
like you're talking about my juicy
little tits yeah or my juicy big tits
where is the sexual door and how do I
reach it yeah yeah so then he was like
yeah I like to [__] you know I was like
boots and she was like yeah yeah that
that meant he heard you were just trying
to throw him off a little bit well let's
close the sexual door your mom is here
yeah close the sexual Mama's here what
do you call it my future wife Egypt
mom just mom there's no
nothing she calls me [__] I have to
call her mom
okay that's her favorite word for me mom
that's why I live when your mommy's
playing with you or that in bed she goes
can you eat my dog oh she just came back
and you lick my daughter please
why did you bring your mom here we
thought it would be
oh you [__] up hey man let's talk
don't talk like that about your
mother-in-law brother no Mom
oh [__] makes really taboo how about
grape leaves what are they called her
great her dolma is
where where are you guys are you from
the same place no you had me at baklava
though yeah it's in the sexual door
right now it wasn't enough I know um
they're making icons you do have a
taxable brokerage account on stock
options right yes Mom I need a big pan
of baklava
language that you can communicate in no
I speak I speak Spanish
You're Mexican no no way but I grew up
with Mexican what's your racial identity
I'm a Syrian Jew but born and raised in
America but my family's from Kerala
yeah where's Kerala Toyota Caroline I
see some Browns here do you all know
where that is okay
shifa
that's the Syrian city right ma'am ma'am
don't even try ma'am I'm gonna need you
to stop with the outbursts I feel like
if you guys keep talking there's a car
bomb that's going to go off
for real I'm getting scared
I'm like damn this is real life
that's cool you guys are both from the
Mena region
um
Asia you [__] we're from Syria yeah but
it's in Kerala it's in South India so
we're both Asian okay unless you don't
consider me Asian whoa is that a
challenge am I am I supposed to connect
through a math challenge right now yeah
don't make it a spelling bee because
he's gonna win
I can't spell your name coriander c o no
sorry
we are the spelling bee Champions though
the South Indians yes you guys are good
at spelling words that are not your
language yeah it's crazy yeah yeah yeah
yeah
well you were very good at speaking it
until they get to the word
supercalifragilisticexpialidocious oh
that's fine that's hard to say are you
popular that's way too fun for an
immigrant what is this so you first have
to have electricity then you first have
to you have to have the movie and then
you have to watch it and then understand
it you didn't be able to say that
hey but if you don't like any of these
guys I'll be happy to go home and I'll
lick your toes
no that's okay I'll put some home or
something post
well not required you can say now you
know maybe uh you want to clean your own
bedroom tonight yeah I'll clean my own
bedroom I guess
um I think y'all are all beautiful
though hey uh have you ever I love you
too man have you have you ever had sex
in a hammock I've never had sex you want
to try that tonight no okay she's a
virgin
have you ever deflowered a man you look
like my tampon maybe he has he has that
photo
as I put my tampon in my [__] yeah
that's the problem then I go to Chipotle
what that's a dirty joke I'm sorry
that's just dirt it was a dirty joke
well uh thank you so much for coming up
again Dahlia and giving it uh
yeah Indian man a chance the Syrian
Indian Jew is here very much yeah what
up for Dahlia give it up for Philip
Abraham you can find him on ATT chat as
John
ktnt chat
for all your internet needs we got Ryan
dent a straight man coming up and he
sounds white he sounds straight there's
a right over there Ryan Joe Rogan
Bitcoin and eating ass
oh he did the little hop
nice to meet you Ryan dance beautiful
man nice kid nice shoes got hops white
men can jump yeah don't tell Kelly Shea
what's up guys Ryan dance what's
happening all right how's your uh dating
life are you actually single yeah
okay what why'd you have to think about
it yeah I'm single is your boyfriend
watching you're afraid he's gonna hate
you no no nice single ready to [__]
put your penis in something yeah sure
thank you for laughing no one else did
um what what are you looking for killing
it by the way oh thank you thank you we
know
um you have a very nice teeth thanks bro
perfect teacher what's going on
underneath that beanie why are you
hiding your beautiful locks of hair do
you have swastikos tattooed on your head
no I just shaved my uh I buzzed my head
for the first time in 15 years oh wow
can we see him sure
whoa oh it looks good thank you I
thought it was don't lie to him no it's
good I think it looks good yeah you look
like Lance Armstrong is one testicle
local uh Austin hero Austin hero he has
a whole bite not a hero in France but
he's a hero in Texas God damn it yeah no
nowadays a woman I've heard they're into
um men without hair because it's like
more powerful like the rock or Jeff
basis but the only downside of that is
that you have to have a lot of money do
you have a lot of money you look like
you have a Roth IRA
oh you just have an IRA oh okay oh you
act like you have an IRA and you're in
the ira
he has that kind of I kind of just think
that it's all uh like 401ks and all
that's just it's a big scam to get
everybody to like join in you know so it
just inflates the assets of the people
who already have money in that yeah so I
technically have one but I don't really
that's not my main it's my main thing
okay well you actually made it serious
let's just joke around for a little bit
no that's what that's what people with
privilege say you know yeah when you
have it so easy you find a way to be
like this doesn't work why is people
giving me extra money it doesn't make
any sense
why are they matching 50 of my
investments I don't get it this is what
it's like to date a white guy he's gonna
start talking about the Federal Reserve
next yeah oh that's a scam I'll get you
started everything is a problem to him
it's like at Costco they gave us too
much chicken
that's a comparison what to do oh to be
white
you're white though thank you you
established that earlier thank you yes
got certified
certified white that's right by a real
Nazi but your your your arm tattoo looks
like hands Heritage
hands Heritage yeah that's my name like
Korean paintings and stuff I'm just
saying it looks nice Are You full Korean
I'm full correct no he's not thick guy
it's only from this house is not exactly
a name I've heard if I had a drop of
white blood in me my eyes would be 20
wider it was pure Asian squintiness my
favorite Koreans are North Koreans
because you're not able to see them
yeah North Koreans have the uh
uh the eyes of South Koreans but the
diet of Venezuelans
that is true
so this is a very nice amiable man he
has not said anything racist or sexist
yet he is uh the top one percent of all
the people we've had on this show
he probably hits women though
he's got uh I'm a police officer and
I've seen a lot of stress on the job
energy
hey well I mean just the face I guess
you've been smiling a lot very kind
happy man
that's terrible who
four women over here
do you know this guy are you filming him
or that's a that's just a cup that's no
Paparazzi any single ladies that would
like to know this young man over here I
like this girl right here
I like him here she comes
point and you shall receive
yeah oh she's uh yeah
but a little drunk
when you drink too much [__]
whoa thankfully you're not on the date
okay 90 seconds with Kylie and the man
the beautiful man Ryan dent
starting now
hey oh that's my voice yeah so the
obvious first question is how did you
lose your voice
well I'm hoping it's not the answer we
got before although I mean do you I
guess but is actually that oh wow is
that weird what's what's considered like
too much
once you put it on the Rocks wow how do
you how do you even obtain that
you sure you don't want to just tell the
real answer
I
oh [__] okay yeah loud's good I don't
mind loud do you like when a guy's loud
maybe not loud but do you like like
local Violet dead silent like like a
plank of wood never say anything ever
nothing
okay before during and after
okay
all right so you uh silent most of the
time I'm clearly not silent but uh yeah
what are your tattoos
oh God
uh is that Medusa yeah well no it's a
bunch of it's a bunch of stuff we can
get into that later it's it's really not
uh terribly
important for everybody else all right
what's with the what's your ring
my grandma gave it
she still with us she is oh wow is she
also in the crowd
yeah yeah she's right there and time
she's also Egyptian apparently
are you actually this one woman has
given birth to this whole show
it's like that that guy that saved a
bunch of Jews during the Holocaust and
then he's at the show and they all stand
up and they're like we are we're all
Jews
well thank you for coming on the show
you lost your voice I wish Alyssa had
your voice but actually it's just you
how's your uh how's your South by
Southwest going obviously pretty good
yeah it's been great it's my best
friend's birthday
which one that's important to women how
old are you turning
23. nice she's legal don't do it
what is your color
okay you're one of I can also [__] with
Ryan
you also have to shorten your dick oh no
it's
um that's cool it's your birthday South
by Southwest you're here anyways Ryan
you're loud in bed
I wouldn't say I'm loud I'm just I've
heard some girls say that they like when
you're expressive you know you
communicate in the bedroom he meant to
say non-verbally he had good parents are
your parents still together oh no oh no
so your mom was just [__] random
people and you're like oh I want to
sound like that guy well
yeah I was like taking notes from down
the block nice
down the block it's like a Forrest Gump
situation you have to sit outside you
know how else how it's going to get into
uh you know the gifted class I guess if
what do you sound what noises do you
make can you make a noise that you make
during sex
he's a bird person
has it been a challenging Mating Season
the biggest fear blood is there Birds
that's a very weird sound to make can
you imagine enough having sex with this
guy and then you hear that holy [__] I'm
not a girl but I would immediately call
my Uber get me out of here do you drive
an Uber you just get in your car yeah
that is true that is true
um so if you can you guys if you have to
give each other a compliment a sincere
compliment while looking into each
other's eyes can you do that
do you think I think we could manage
okay
go go well I gave her the compliment of
saying that I liked her and I wanted to
come up here okay another one number two
uh I like the way that she got on stage
with no stairs no help yeah yeah that
was gonna really tells you you can tell
she [__] with her shoes yeah they could
tell she loses her voice during South by
Southwest yeah yeah because the way she
gets on that's too much too many
cigarettes
a mix of everything were you at a show
what show were you at where you lost
your words are trying to protect her One
Direction Harry Styles no no I don't
like Harry Styles
producer Sam Kuiper sniping from the
back yeah actually no idea
so you're just black out really long
weekend okay
yeah but you did some screaming at some
point we can assume probably okay what
both loud in bed what what about me you
get on stage or did you find him
attractive or anything about him that
you could say in front of us maybe the
color wipes
thank you yeah the shoes are good your
live shoe from top to bottom
nothing like complement complementing a
material item
yes
that's their head or your head yeah yeah
whoa she's judging heads now there's a
woman with no voice I'd rather I'd
rather have this type of like raspy
almost non-existent voice than like a
vocal fry so yeah it's way worse when
you can hear everything they say
[Laughter]
well thank you guys for being on the
show you guys might actually date each
other so that's a plus but not necessary
it is a dating show uh thank you thank
you what was your name Kaylee Kylie
Kylie thank you Kylie Kylie from
over there
thanks and Robert Ryan Dent give it a
foreign got a comic book name yeah
well that was the show thank you for
watching people date we did it we
watched them do it thank you thank you
hands for having me as your guest this
was the first time for me I had a lot of
fun I got to practice English in front
of a beautiful audience and it got I
think I got myself a date you know Dalia
your mom both of you we can go home I
don't care let's do it let's make it
happen up for a friend thank you guys
friend come on drive safe love you guys
good night